the ability first of all to validate
that the solution
um
is the right solution for for the need
and then
to do the first pilot
uh and to move to commercialization
that's
a huge advantage
uh for the startups and and of course
that
shortens the cycle
uh from from few years to to
maybe a year
full commercialization
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
this episode is powered by jay ventures
a community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright xl
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about mobility and automotives meet avi
feldman founder and managing partner of
mobilion ventures
avi has brought experience and a proven
track record in building innovative
startups from the bottom up as well as
leading venture capital investments
before founding mobilion ventures avi
served as the ceo of capital nature an
early stage investment company that
focuses on green energy and smart
mobility and led the funds notable
investments of millions of dollars in
leading startups avi founded the
regional development center at the
israeli ministry of industry trade and
labor and served as its first director
prior to that he was senior deputy legal
advisor for the ministry
avi feldman has an llm from the hebrew
university of jerusalem and an empa from
syracuse university in new york
avi feldman welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you for joining me today how are
you
very good thank you for having me thank
you so much for being here and you're
today with the mobilion ventures
you've been
dealing with mobility but also renewable
energy for for quite some time
with capital nature but also previously
in the ministry you know within the
ministry of in israel you're coming from
a legal background yet i it sounds you
know just objectively looking at your
trajectory that you grew to have this
deeper and deeper conviction of where
you really want to to have the impact
and what you really want to be doing
leveraging on your previous experiences
so what i would love to start with
obvious tell me a little bit about your
journey and and how you reach to decide
that you want to spend the majority of
your time dealing both with with
investments
you know in companies but then
specifically in mobility and green
energy
i think that uh um
most of the things that we're going to
touch upon
are things that
emerge together
um just in in recent years um
you know as as a child i'm
i would say a child of nature i grew up
in in a small village
always
uh up in the open uh outside
um
and and nature is something that i i
care about uh you know
back from home uh uh
both
traveling and and and
the the whole family history is around
uh uh nature preservance uh uh my father
is part of the
uh israel uh israeli association for uh
for the nature and and so on so
i come with with
deep environmental engagement
um that's on one side and the other side
is you know the geek part
uh so um
yeah i started in in high school i
studied computer science uh and and
excel with it
it was
i really was uh uh
uh into it as a child uh um
following that being in in the army in
um
a very exclusive
technological unit
um
so
all the time around those two pillars
but but
only lately they they converge together
to to right
um
uh to be you know
an active part of my of my professional
life
uh and i think that uh uh the the first
uh uh
major part was in the ministry of
economy i was
um deputy director general in the
ministry responsible for
uh the the development of the periphery
so regional economic development
um
and
when i came to this uh to that uh uh
role
uh i was looking for something that the
periphery would have
you know a built-in
uh advantage in and and cleantech
uh is obviously one of the of um
a leading sector that that uh peripheral
areas have advantage in in promoting
the peripheries have an advantage in
cleantech energy systems
so uh uh first of all you have uh um you
know uh rural areas uh that you can
develop a lot of uh large-scale projects
uh either wind solar uh agree
um everything that's connected to the
environment your your uh able to do
there uh also most of the the research
infrastructures
uh with regard to to the environment are
are
usually in in these kind of places for
example
in a lot you you find the uh
inter-university
uh uh school for for uh uh marine
biology right um
you'll find those things only in the
periphery
uh so i used cleantech back then in in
the ministry of economy as to
the prayer freezing social crisis
right
um
and from that point
the the interest just just grew
uh later on you know uh leaving
leaving the the the governmental side uh
for the uh uh the the private sector uh
but doing the same just looking for
um
the ventures themselves the the the the
startups uh the entrepreneurs
that
uh are able to to to do so and to
demonstrate that new technologies can
and will
uh bring change to to
you know the climate the environment and
what brings you to converge on on
mobility after after spending several
years with capital nature you're looking
at a variety right of of renewable
energy you know companies and and but
most recently now you're converging
specifically on the mobility sector
sure so i think that what's interesting
i'm talking about
you know energy uh and green energy on
one side mobility on the other side
uh
and and actually the nexus of
the two of them
is very powerful
uh the
the two sectors are are uh undergoing uh
uh tremendous change i would say that uh
uh disruption in in the last uh uh few
years
each
on its own um
you know based on on
different trends in in each of them and
and the policies also uh uh with regard
to the governmental
aid but the nexus of of both of them so
for one
hand on the energy side you have the
ability
uh to generate new energy
uh that is not based on on fossil fuels
and
on the other side you're able to
transform that energy into mobility
um
and and take the the the
whole transportation sector
into
a totally new different uh
uh propulsion and and and uh um
uh way of uh um
dealing with energy and and preserving
energy and and so so this nexus is is
very powerful it combines the two
uh in a very uh specific way
um
i'll give you you know two two
great examples from my uh for former
portfolio um
so uh the first company is electron i
don't know if uh
uh you know them but uh
this is a startup that started in
capital nature
um some
seven eight years ago
um
they developed the electric road
uh
so how to transfer electricity from the
road
to the to the vehicle
uh another startup is yeah chakra tech
uh
doing uh uh through flywheel converging
energy
uh from the grid to the vehicle
uh in very uh uh um
short times so
hyper charging uh uh vehicles
uh those are examples for for new
technologies that a few years ago were
were
unreachable or not part of our
um
mix of technologies that we were able to
use and that's
that's something that i
i'm passionate about
and and what is your involvement sort of
with these companies as you're you know
as you're meeting quite a few
entrepreneurs you're working with a lot
of different companies in the mobility
and renewable space
what is your engagement with them as
they're going to prove
these new ways of of producing mobility
and energy
so
going now to to
to mobilion uh which is my my new uh
my new vc
um
we are working with our entrepreneurs in
hand-in-hand uh um
on on a daily and weekly basis so it's
really hands-on
uh approach
uh
but giving them you know the full scale
of uh
we're not intervening in in the
day-to-day uh more in the strategic uh
um
decision making and and and
moreover we are trying to provide them
with access to to
channels that
are not open
to them today
and this is
i think that the basic
um
the basic attribute that uh uh a vc
a good vc can bring to to its portfolio
startups uh are
good connections good channels to to
market good channels to partnership uh
you have to bring value and and that's
basically the the the way to to
uh
to generate um
value for your portfolio companies
right now
what what do you
you know what can you share from your
experience
working with entrepreneurs specifically
in the cleantech green energy mobility
space
you know that their journey might be a
little bit different more or less
challenging you know and in what ways
than than that of traditional
entrepreneurs that aren't in this space
so what is unique to those working in
the specific space that you're in that
you've learned
that that really is something else that
it is not trivial for other people to to
really understand
i think that uh the two sectors uh
that
i'm involved in
and basically the the
transportation mobility automotive
uh
it's very dominant that most of the
companies
uh out there are
you know uh uh multi-billion dollar
companies right uh dominating their
their markets
uh
it's not saying that they don't have
competition but but those are
you know
uh super giants yes uh and working with
with startups is something that uh is
um
very challenging to for them uh to do so
the the the the
uh the sizes and the cultures are so
different
uh
so um
you know a regular
uh entrepreneur thinks well i have a
great solution i'll knock on the door uh
they'll uh immediately
uh understand that uh what i have to
offer is so unique and so surprising and
and they'll embrace me in a minute and
and
uh
it doesn't work that way and in the
automotive industry
uh it takes years upon years to to
really
create that engagement and and yes
uh to provide that
um and i think that
you know in in mobility we have a very
uh uh
different
uh approach where we try to bring
uh startups to the the
um
mobility industry
uh through the aftermarket
so you know what does that mean you
think of
uh so i'll explain usually uh when you
look at um
you know automotive mobility uh
you're going for the big names uh that
are the the oems right so uh
um you know i can name them one by one
you know the german manufacturers and
the the the u.s based one and
japanese and koreans and and so on
everybody knows that
the names
but to work with them it would take you
five uh seven maybe eight years until
you'll see your technology embedded upon
a new vehicle
uh integrated all the whole way
uh what we offer them is something
completely different we are saying look
that's great but let's let's take a
parallel uh venue and this venue goes to
the aftermarket so selling directly
uh
to the end user it could be fleet
managers
uh
it could be
um
the the the the the private owner
uh so b2b and b2c uh together and we are
doing that through
uh uh a sector it is a it's a sub sector
within the automotive industry that is
called the aftermarket and and many
uh uh
channels
uh that are out there
and are part of our ecosystem um we've
partnered with the major player in the
automotive in the in the global
automotive
uh um
aftermarket which is nexus automotive
international they are uh the biggest
uh trading group
within that
that sector accounting for more than 30
billion euros per year of sales
unbelievable that's that's huge uh
having
distributors all over so in more than
140 countries
uh
so that's a huge power the ability to
knock on every door in the industry
either
uh the manufacturing side or the
distribution side
that's
uh a huge advantage
and i think that
any of our startups i'm able to take
them either to the manufacturing side or
to
a potential geographical
distributor that that controls a certain
uh
a certain region
um and to validate first of all to
validate if if the technology is right
uh for certain uses
um i'll give you an example
one of our portfolio companies clickings
they do uh automated damage detection
yeah
we took them to one of the biggest u.s
based
companies they are doing
uh
hundreds of thousands of
car
detections on an annual base
so close to 1 million detections per per
year
the ability first of all to validate
that the solution
is
the right solution for for the need
and then
to do the first pilot
uh and to move to commercialization
that's
a huge advantage
uh for the startups and and of course
that
shortens the cycle
uh from from few years to to
maybe a year uh full commercialization
right and that's obviously with the
power of having you know a strong vc
backing you that is not just you know
not just putting capital but also has
that added value of being domain
specific having those partnerships in
place having gained that trust that a
young startup would take years to gain
that trust right i guess that's that's
that's the big value out here first of
all yeah first of all it's to open the
door then to create the the
the connection and the engagement
between the two right and then the
ability to to to bridge
again between the the the
the young startup with all the the
enthusiastic but but
lacking of uh uh the the ability to to
uh to understand what's the other side
need and what the timeline to do so and
how to build that over time
um
that is the the real value that
we can bring so i think that
the major lesson i took from
uh
my previous years both in the in the
um
ministry of economy and and afterwards
in in capital nature and i brought it to
mobilion as part of our
uh basic model
is always look for uh ways to cooperate
with with with the giants right um
you have to create some kind of platform
that they will find themselves
um
um interested in being engaged
looking for for
uh what you can offer them
uh and building that to scale
so
you know you know
one of our uh
lp's is uh mitsubishi ko uh the mother
company of mitsubishi motors and isuzu
um
and when we negotiated with them you
know
being part of the of the fund and so on
they told me look
we know
how to handle a startup that has let's
say 10 million dollars of sales right uh
and you need to scale it
but we don't know how to touch a startup
that doesn't have any sales or or only
limited
uh the the the initial sales we need you
to be there to help us
uh uh bridge that gap
beautiful
i love it and i think that that's ex
that really exemplifies the work that
you do and you already answered one of
the questions that i enjoy asking
earlier on when you talked about you
know your connection to nature but also
your connection to stem but what really
inspires you today in the work that
you're doing you're choosing to remain
on on the on the investment side on the
connector side what what really inspires
you in in your day today
i think that
the nexus between uh investments and and
the environment so so uh
uh mitigating the the the
climate change uh uh challenges right
uh through technological new
technologies that that can
really solve not only
needs of the industry but also needs of
social needs and and environmental needs
i think that
uh when
we are able to to do so to find uh
technologies
that are
um
both answers the the the economical need
and the environmental need i think it's
it's a
it's a match that that gives you
extra
uh
interest in in doing the investment in
in promoting that startup in in
so so
double and triple bottom lines are are
highly welcome and uh and when we are
you know in search for for those because
uh you know doing
being just the bank
yeah it's not enough doing good
investment that's not good enough
we need something else we need to to to
prove that uh
uh
we're doing good by by doing good
investments i love it and what are three
words that you would use to describe
yourself
uh so so i think that
first and foremost is uh you know
entrepreneurial spirit i think that i'm
i consider myself to be one uh before
coming to to
um to look for for others and to invest
in them
uh i think that that
what i've done in the past either on the
governmental side were
much of it was uh entrepreneurs
um
capital nature now mobility
those are our
uh first evers so i've created something
from from stretch
i love it i love the the challenge in it
so that that would be
uh
number one
um
i think that the
also the the
the ability to to
to see
a complete picture
um
and not just the the the the
the items themselves and and and the
challenges in in each of them but
seeing the whole picture and
understanding the whole picture i think
it's it's something that i
i i like to to to to zoom out yeah
and and and i think that by that
many of the of the
day-to-day challenges are are you you're
able to to overlook them and
find first is so it's it's
um uh
how to architect the the right building
box so start with
uh uh the zoom out and then
as you go to higher resolution on the
way you you solve the the
um the right uh challenges uh uh in the
right order
[Music]
and the third i
i think that
i hope that the the
it was also uh uh uh
you could feel it in that interview i'm
i'm i'm passionate about what one i do
what we're doing
yeah in in mobilia and i think that uh
you should be passionate about
uh
what you do the way you do it uh and if
you're
able to to to do so uh you're able also
to to
attract others
uh
and and
so
i'll go for
those three avi thank you very very much
this was wonderful and continue doing
great work great investments uh in the
mobility space and in the renewable
energy space i love the connection all
the way from the childhood to the stem
to legal to to working in the public
sector but then private sector thank you
for all the amazing work and stay safe
and stay healthy thank you very much
again thank you for having me and uh i
hope that
all our listeners uh enjoy the the
i have no doubt thank you take care
thank you very much bye-bye